all right let's hear from some of you
through the Friday feedback segment
where emails Facebook comment YouTube
comments smoke signals telegrams Twitter
replies all sorts of communications with
the show may be featured on Fridays if
you just want to keep it simple and send
an email you can email info
davidpackman.com I have to admit this
first message I don't understand if this
is from a Nazi or from someone warning
me about Nazis and saying they have
taken over the message is as follows the
weak fear the swastika you all had your
chances to deal with this you dropped
the ball we told you for years we are
everywhere and eventually we would have
to come out well here we are now it's
our time to deal with these Weimar
conditions welcome to national socialism
is this a Nazi saying we have now taken
over because you didn't stop us or is
this an anti-nazi saying because you
didn't stop them the Nazis are now here
I genuinely have no idea
someone else knows what that message is
about
please let me know the anti-trans
movement continues and it continues
plaguing our YouTube channel user desro
QC says thank God for people like
Michael Knowles and Matt Walsh these are
anti-trans guys from the daily wire
fighting against the groomers who are
aiming their filth at our children we
are way past being polite and tolerant
with you bunch of degenerates trying to
indoctrinate confuse and mutilate kids
uh I don't know
what this person is talking about and as
I've said before
it seems as though no one is aiming
anything at children but we do have
things that exist which parents can
decide I will bring my kid to that
or I won't bring my kid to that and that
that's the freedom I thought the right
wing advocated for I thought that's
exactly what they wanted it's very
confusing rated ARG has a different view
about the anti-trans Hysteria and says
let's find a small marginalized group of
harmless people and really stomp on them
and make their lives miserable just to
show how big and strong and brave we are
you know this reminded me it's a very
good point this reminded me of Arnold
Schwarzenegger's recent video 12-minute
video which was it dealt with
discrimination of all kinds and
certainly you could tell that he was
pushing back against the anti-trans
rhetoric but it was also pushing back
against anti-Semitism and one of the
great points that Arnold made
referring to his own father who was a
Nazi sympathizer was all of these
movements these groups these coalitions
based on hate they end up being losers
at the end of the day they you never
look back at them and say those were the
winners the people who opposed women
voting
we don't those were the losers they they
hindered obvious progress in the United
States the Nazis in World War II of
course the anti-gay people who for 20
years shouted about too many if you let
two men marry next thing you know people
will be allowed to marry horses
they're losers they are and when you
look at this comment which is it's not a
very big thing big and I'm by big I mean
Alpha right to choose the weakest people
and to say that's who we're going to go
after excellent comment and I couldn't
uh couldn't agree more
um here's a comment about critical race
Theory this individual why am I why am I
Mr Pink says the issue with critical
race theory is that it teaches the idea
that systemic racism is a thing when it
is not no one on the right wants to stop
the teaching of History they hate the
lies about it also history is complex
take the issue of slavery after slavery
was banned many still worked for their
owners why why didn't they pursue a new
career and become landowners because
many were fine in the position they were
in that last part is pretty crazy the
reason some slaves continued working for
their owners when they were technically
freed was that there was still all sorts
of between the lines discrimination that
was allowed and was happening and
because many of those folks in their
individual situations didn't really have
much of a choice with what money were
they going to go and buy land
it doesn't make any sense but let's go
to the to the more important part it
teaches the idea that systemic racism is
a thing when it is not
listen there have been major advances in
the United States when it comes to
dealing with systemic racism of
different kinds and that has taken place
to different degrees we still have a
number of different systemic realities
in the United States that go above and
beyond the individual for example there
are still significant effects when it
comes to public transit in many cities
where the historically redlined
neighborhoods disproportionately
um uh uh represented by minorities are
much less well connected via public
transit that's a systemic issue that's a
systemic issue where in certain
neighborhoods you're going to have more
of an issue getting to jobs in certain
parts of the city
and the reason that that is the case is
because it is a Vestige of uh racial
racist redlining okay that's a systemic
issue that doesn't mean every aspect of
society is racist there have been a
number of interesting studies done where
the same resumes are submitted with
traditionally identifiably white
sounding names and black sounding names
no difference whatsoever when it comes
to the credentials and the white
sounding names are much more likely to
get an initial interview that's a
systemic issue you could be the idea is
you're just disqualified but because of
a name that is stigmatized with a
particular race you're less likely to
even get the opportunity to prove
yourself in an interview that's a
systemic issue
now that doesn't mean that there haven't
been great improvements made as well so
the idea that there are no systemically
racist issues doesn't make much sense
Gerald says I wish every Republican
doing an interview would be asked
explain what critical race theory is and
explain what woke is yeah me too we've
talked about this before when they are
asked to explain critical race Theory
they usually spit out it teaches white
kids that they are bad because they're
white I missed that day in class and
when you ask them about woke I mean last
week even Fox host Dana Perino said woke
can just be a feeling or a sense
um here's another question relating the
uh drag show stuff to I guess
irresponsible parenting this user user
says would you David hand the car keys
to your child and say go have fun go as
fast as you want this is equal to taking
your child to a drag show
that escalated pretty quickly no I mean
listen in 16 years I will start teaching
my daughter how to drive
and I will teach her the rules of the
road and I will teach her about road
safety and she will have to go to
Driver's Ed and complete a number of
hours of driver training and all of that
and then I will still continue to
espouse the need to be careful when
driving and I can't think of any way
in which that relates at all to a drag
show I just I'm I'm really racking my
brain
and I'm not understanding how there's a
connection between learning to drive
safely
and taking a kid to a drag show maybe
someone can explain it to me
giddy one posted to the subreddit
about me saying no president has ever
been arrested that it is false
and I received a few of these messages
this particular post says President
Ulysses S Grant or if I were Trump I
would pronounce it Ulysses but it's
Ulysses S Grant was arrested in 1872 for
Dangerous driving he was fined and did
not contest the arrest or fine then
going on to say President Franklin
Pierce was arrested for running over a
pedestrian while driving his carriage in
Washington possibly drunk driving he was
arrested but released when his identity
became known so two things about this
it is absolutely the case that I
misspoke and I I wanted to say indicted
which I think would have made my comment
more accurate but my research suggests
that the Franklin Pierce story
is questioned what I've read conflicting
accounts and some say that it is not a
true story about Franklin Pierce
but I'm not sure but in any case it does
appear that Trump wouldn't be the first
president arrested but I believe from my
research it is accurate to say indicted
but we are going to continue looking
into it very very strongly
another post from the subreddit asks and
this this hits Home Folks
is social media just not worth it
it's so goddamned infuriating logging on
and seeing the most smugly brain dead
easily debunked BS get thousands of
likes and shares I gave up arguing with
them long ago because exactly zero of
them will change their minds as a result
and I'll just get agitated with the
stupidity while they fly back to the
flock to claim victory I know ignoring
these clowns won't make them go away but
man is it frustrating
I have said for a long time
I don't engage in social media arguments
now it's easy for me to say because I
have a platform where I can do much more
in an hour than in 10 hours arguing with
individuals on Twitter I understand not
everybody has that but my advice
continues to be I don't know that I
would either get involved with it for me
social media is I want to see what is
being said but it's not for them
starting to type furiously at people
that's I I believe it is an exercise in
frustration and I sympathize with that
completely we try on our platforms like
the very subreddit that this this
message is from we try to make it a
more positive and controlled environment
we don't allow you know direct
harassment and of course people can
disagree we don't allow slurs and these
sorts of things but at the end of the
day sometimes it's just wow your
opinions really aren't based in fact and
there's really nothing I can do about
that and that is certainly a sad thing
but I would agree with this person's
view ignoring won't make them go away
but arguing with them on Twitter won't
make them change their minds and so we
have to work in a different way we have
to work through campaigns we have to
work through activism and that is much
more effective than you know arguing
with someone on Tick Tock or whatever
the case may be get your messages in
info davidpackman.com or through any of
the other means that you can get in
touch with us we will have such a great
bonus show for you today and if you
don't have access to the bonus show
because you're not a member then we will
be back on Monday with a new podcast for
you